Herkese
merhabalar ben Doçent Doktor Ece babam
Öncelikle beni davet ettiğiniz için çok
teşekkür ederim Çok heyecanlıyım burada
olduğum için sizin gibi değerli
gençlerin karşısında bulunduğum için ben
size bugün belirli bir süre içerisinde
ki Ben konuşmaya başladığımda maalesef
susmak çok bilmiyorum Benim için çok zor
olacak o yüzden bunu sığdırmak Ama
hayatımda Özellikle de
Kariyerim boyunca ve hayatın boyunca
attığım büyük adımların nasıl
gerçekleştiğini Anlatmaya çalışacağım
Belki size birazcık örnek olabilir ya da
ilham alabilirsiniz asıl sizden Biz
ilham alıyoruz ama arada böyle
karşılıklı değiş tokuşlar çok güzel
oluyor şu
bu şöyle başlayın birazcık ayırdım
bölümlere ayırdığım konuşmamı ilk
attığım adım Bence önemli olarak ve hem
kariyere hem de topluma hizmet olarak
neler yaptığımda ilgili sanırım
üniversite çağında 19 yaşında çalışmaya
başlamakla oldu
Onu ilkokulda tabi benim ilkokulda
olduğum yıllar 1990'lı yıllar o yıllarda
dergi çıkartmak istedim fakat ilkokul
şartlarında böyle bir şey Mümkün değil o
zamanlar böyle blok blok A4 kağıtları da
yok Dolayısıyla kendi defter lerimizden
kopardığımız kağıtlarla üç dört
arkadaşını topladım dedim ki biz daha
iyi çıkartabiliriz Nasıl yapacağız
dergiyi çıkartmaya gittim önce Müdürlüğü
hocalarla konuştum yok mümkün değil
dediler peki dedim okuldakiler ile
sohbet ettim hangi haberler var hangi
dersleri alıyorlar Biz elimi ne diyoruz
vesaire böyle küçük dosyalar haline
getirdik de okulda ilk dergi çıkarttı
ımızı düşündük o zamanlar sonrasında
tabi ilkokul dediğimiz dönem daha çok
sınavları hazırlıkla geçen bir dönemde o
zaman Daha sonrasında gittiğim lisede
canlı olan bu Lisesi'ne gittim orada
yine Yokuşu krediye bir dergi
çıkartıyordu yokuş yukarı dergisini
içerisinde bir şeyler yapmaya çalıştım
ama bu arada öğrencilik Kariyerim çok
inişli çıkışlı öğrencilik hayatı
başarılı hayatım Neden Çünkü sadece tek
bir ders yen sadece ders çalışma odaklı
bir bana ilkokulda dedim ki iyi bak
anadolu lisesini kazandıktan sonra rahat
olacaksın artık birşey yapmayacaksın Ben
de iyiyim Anadolu Lisesi'ni kazandım
Daha sonrasında dedim ki artık çalışmama
gerek yok çalışmayacağım bir şey
yapacağım Bu çocuğa ne oldu Neden
çalışmıyorsun Hani montları neden bu
kadar kötü Almanca eğitim alıyoruz
Almanca'yı da çok fazla çözemediği mi
düşünüyorum da çok zorlu bir süreç
geçirdim sonunda bir gün artık annemi
sürekli okula çağırıyorlar Bir gün
geldiğinde bizim üst sınıftaki
öğrenciler genellikle hocalarla veliler
arasında tercümanlık yapıyorlar O
tercümanlıkta kimseyi bulamadık ve o
tercümanı ben yapmak zorunda kaldım bu
Hayatımdaki en önemli kırılma
noktalarından biriydi Çünkü orta 2
deydim ve annemle Almanca öğretmenim
arasında tamamen konuşmayı var yaptıktan
sonra dedim ki Evet ben bunu
konuşabiliyorum Demek ki Birazcık da
ders çalışabilirim ve sonrasında hem
Kültür Sanat konusunda geliştirip hem de
işte üniversite sınavına hazırlanıyor
bir süreç geçti dergiciliği orada bir
şekilde okulun içinde devam etmeye
çalıştım aynı zamanda tiyatro neden
önemli olduğunu söyleyeceğim size
tiyatroda da çok değerli isimlerden
eğitim aldık yine okuduğumuz bize
içerisinde yarışmalara katıldık ödüller
aldık vesaire Z Bu üniversite hayatına
geçtiğimde dedim ki bu arada uçak
mühendisi olmak istiyordum ilk başta
fakat uçak mühendisi için SM okumamız
gerekiyor benim öyle bir yeteneğim kimya
konusunda yok bende Türkçe matematik
seçim dedim Bu arada bütün seçimlerini
de ailem bana bıraktı bu inanılmaz bir
özgüven Dolayısıyla seçimlerinizi
yaparken sizlerinde Özellikle bu konuda
kendi fikirlerinizi kendi istediğiniz
hedeflerinizi belirlemeniz Çok önemli
çünkü lisede lise 1'de bölüm seçme
toplantıları oluyordu oraya Mesela
herkesin birisi gitti Ben kendim gittim
çünkü bana dediler ki sen okuyacaksın
mutsuz olacağım bir şeydi suçu bize
atacağını git konuş hocalarım lan Ne
istiyorsan onu yap peki dedim gittim ben
de orada bütün hocalarla konuştum dedi
Hatice sen TM seç Peki
sonrasında Marmara İletişim fakültesine
girdim Marmara iletişimde yine tiyatroya
devam ettim Fotoğrafçılık öğrenmeye
başladım bu ve
yazarlık yarışması var üniversitelere
siona katıldım oradan derece aldım dedim
tamam ben iyi bir yazar olabilirim
matematikçi olduğum için ekonomi ders
var kimse bir şey anlamıyor dersen ben
anladım arkadaşlarımı sınıfa topladım 10
kişiye dedim ki ben size bunu anlatayım
onları anlattım Biz 10 kişi geçtik
sınıfın gerisi kaldı dedim ki Evet beni
ders anlatabiliyorum O zaman ben
akademisyenlikte bir şekilde yani
aldığım bilgi paylaşa biliyorum bir
şekilde akademisyenlikte belki
yapabilirim ve akademisyenliği giden
yolculuğun bu şekilde başlamış oldu
sonunda üniversiteyi bitirdikten sonra
hemen akademisyen olarak Marmara
Üniversitesi'nde işe başladım Bunun yanı
sıra 19 yaşında dergicilik dedim ki
Kendi ayaklarının üstünde durmam
gerekiyor işte sanırım attım en önemli
adımlardan bir tanesi oydu
bütün dergileri topladım gittim Bir
kitapçıya oradan bütün dergileri
topladım künyeleri açtım isimleri
çıkarttım o zaman bu atabiliyoruz
internet böyle PDF şeklindeki pedefiler
de yani şu küçük diye böyle dönen
sayfalardan Hani karşılıklı etkileşim
vesaire hiçbir şey yok oralardan değil
attım herkese kimse bana dönmüyor
gidiyorum Nişantaşı'nda bir numara
Yayıncılık gidiyorum Kimse benle
görüşmek istemiyorum Seni stajyer olarak
alamayız diyor seninle ilgilenemem Ey
izliyor ben de gittim Dedim ki buranın
danışmaya buranın dedim giriş-çıkış
kapısı Neresi burası başka dedim bir
giriş çıkış kapısı var mı hayır yok Peki
ben de burada oturur beklerim dedim
orada beklemeye başladınız Tüh ben Bizim
üniversitede Nişantaşı'nda dersten çıkıp
oraya gidiyorum orada oturuyorum sonunda
benimle görüştüler ve bir erkek
dergisinde çalışmaya başladım Çok zorlu
bir süreç geçirdim arkadaşlar Neden
Çünkü
bana beslediği hayvandan erkeğin
karakter tahlili futbol haberleri
burçlar işte
değil bir sürü konuda araba yarışları
ilgim olan olmayan her konuda haber
yazdırdılar ve hepsini peki dedim 15 gün
sonunda Ama herkes gittikten sonra ben
oturuyorum haber yazmak için çalışıyorum
15 gün sonunda ben özgürce gittim Genel
Yayın yönetmenimiz dedim ki Özgür abi
ben böyle bir şey yazdım Sence işte
dergide yazı yazabilir miyim dedi ki
evet yazabilirsin çok güzel olmuş ve
bana dergide 15 gün sonra stajı bırakıp
19 yaşında yazı işlerinde yazı yazmaya
başladım sonrasında bakın benim
konularım değil bu konulardan bir
iletişim ciğim Ercan Arıklı o zaman
dergi grubunun başında dedim ki Özgür
Özgür abi ben dedim medya ile ilgili bir
şey yapmak istiyorum Ne yapmak
istiyorsun röportajlar yapmak istiyorum
Peki
hazırlayabilecek misin hazırlarım dedim
Ercan Arıklı ile konuşuldu kabul edildi
ve Daha sonrasında Ben Mehmet Ali
birand'dan Ayşe arman'a birçok insanla
daha üniversitede öğrenciyken
röportajlar yapmaya başladım bu ve kendi
bölümü oluşturmuş olduğum derginin
içinde
sonrasında dergicilik kariyerime işte
beni çok meşgulüz Ece seninle
görüşemeyiz diyen kişilerle birlikte
çalıştığım Onlar ayrıldılar ben devam
ettim aktüel dergisinde çalıştım
haftalık dergisinde çalıştığım dijital
yöneticilik yaptım dergi Kariyerim
boyunca dergicilik Şu anda da Global
savunma diye bir dergi Ne haber
müdürlüğünü yapıyorum Diğer taraftan
akademisyenliğe devam ettim çünkü
dördüncü sınıfta biz bitirme tezi
yazıyordu Bitirme tezini
çalışma yaparken yani gazete-dergi de
çalışırken merdiven boşluğunda oturarak
ve orada boş vakitlerinde tezimi yazmaya
çalışarak bitirdim sonunda okulda derece
ile bitirdi mi akademisyen oldum şimdi
akademisyenim süresince
attığım önemli adım neydi bir kere
akademisyen akademisyen olmaya karar
vermek bizim için önemli bir adım ve
yine Marmara devam ettim yüksek
lisansına doktor ama ve sonrasında bir
gün uyandım dedim ki ben başka bir
şehirde uyanmak istiyorum Başka bir şey
yapmak istiyorum akademisyenlik yapmak
istiyorum Başka yerleri görmek istiyorum
Ne yapabilirim
Almanca var bu Sonra gittim sen
sabahleyin kalktım internetin başına
oturdum ya burslara bakıyorum dağıt
bursu Yani Almanya işte Gökçek'in süt
bize verilen burçlardan bir tanesi
Almanca bilenler özellikle ama bütün
akademisyenlere de bir değişim programı
var
bir dedim ki ben bunu başvurabilirim git
bir iki gün var kapanmasını Bursa
başvurdum gittim konuşmamı Orada hem
Almanca konuşup hem yazılı sınava girdim
kimsenin haberi yok Bu arada bunu
yaptığımda da ve sonuçları bekliyorum
sonuçlar geldi birkaç ay sonra
Çok da tın üstün başarı bursu kazandım
ve Almanya yine gideceğim ama ailemin
haberi yok daha bu yaptığım şeyler
Onlara haber verdim neyse işte sonrası
Almanya'da gittim siyasal iletişim
çalıştım ve akademi'nin farklı yüzlerini
gördüm farklı akademisyenlerle çalıştım
ve benim için çok önemli bir katkısı
oldu Daha sonrasında Geri döndüğümde
Almanya'dan yine önemli bir adım attım
Marmara Üniversitesi'nden ayrıldım başka
bir vakıf Üniversitesi'ne geçti mi orada
baktım kendi bölüm açabiliyorum daha
fazla rekabetçi bir ortam var daha çok
kendimi geliştirebilirim ve sonrasında
en son Fenerbahçe Üniversitesi ne kadar
geldim Bu arada yaptığım önemli bir adım
şuydu ikinci doktoraya başladım
Bu benim bana neler kattı onu paylaşmak
istedim Sizinle Uf ya bir aksilik
olmazsa Aralık ayında profesör olacağım
ve
ya hani profesör olacaksın ikinci
doktoru iğneden yapıyorsun diye bana çok
sordular Çünkü belli bir süre sonra bir
alanda çalıştığınız zaman o alanı yavaş
yavaş tüketmeye başladığınızda kendinize
yeni yollar açmamız gerekiyor Ben de
uluslararası ilişkiler alanıyla çok
ilgileniyorum ama stratejiyle çok
ilgileniyorum işte güvenlikle
ilgileniyorum terörle mücadele ile
ilgileniyorum Dolayısıyla kendimi bir
alan açmak istiyorum ama sürekli şuna
karşılaşıyorum bir güvenlik konusunda
İşte Ece yapamazsın iki iletişimcisi
Necesen uluslarası ilişkiler yapamazsın
öyle mi dedim Peki
sadece sanırım dokuz gün kapandı m&v
4 yıllık üniteyi okuyabildiğin kadarını
okudum Marmara Üniversitesi'ni
sınavlarına girdim kimseyi tanımıyorum
iyi açık sınavlardan Çok uzağa Bu arada
ALES sınavına girdim değil sınavına
girdim vesaire ve kazandım sonrasında
yıllık oy kullanarak dersleri gittim
çünkü izin vermiyorlar yani ikinci
Doktor yapıyorsun Ne oluyor sana herkes
bana böyle dehşetli bakıyor neden
yapıyorsun kitapta okuyabilirsin Ya
hayır dedim her mesleğe her alanda
çalışan insana saygı göster onların
verdiği Emeğe saygı göstermeniz
gerekiyor Dolayısıyla Elinizde bir
diploma olduğu zaman siz de oraya emek
vermiş olursunuz ve benim uluslararası
ilişkiler Hikayem böyle başladı
bıt abi derslerimi verdim yeterli mi
geçtim doktora aşamasında yapılabilecek
olan her şeyi yaptıktan sonra bu sefer
farklı alanlarda çalışmaya başladım
Mesela
en büyük hayallerimden bir tanesiydin at
odada eğitim verdim
56 ülkeden gelen komutanları strateji
iletişim ve güvenlik konusunda onlarla
tanışma ve onları bir seminer verme
imkanım oldu Daha sonrasında kendime
Füze Savunma sistemleri alanında
geliştirdim ve nükleer teknolojiler çok
geliştirdim tabi bütün bunları
çalışırken hep karşılaştım şey şuydu çok
erkek Egemen bir alan ve mücadele
etmeniz gerekiyor bu alanda kendi
varlığınızı Hem kabul ettirmek için hem
de gerçekten bu konuda bilgili
olduğunuzu ifade edebilmek için
o mücadeleyi de bir şekilde veriyorsunuz
arkadaşlar Ve ve şu anda Bazen Canlı
yayınlarda tiyatro benim için neden
önemli oldu çünkü bir sahneye Çıktığım
zaman ya da
bir yayına Çıktığım zaman gerçekten
kendimizi doğal ifade edebilecek
Beko heyecanı yenebilecek bir kabiliyet
kazanmış oluyorsunuz birincisi İkincisi
de ki yatro eğitiminde şunu
öğreniyorsunuz insanlara sadece insan
olarak bakmayı yani yaş cinsiyet
herhangi bir ayrım olmadan sadece
karşınızdakini insan olarak görmeyi
öğreniyorsunuz
bu bana inanılmaz bir artı kazandırdı bu
O televizyon alanında bir kariyer
yapmaya başladım Çünkü beraberinde
yurtdışına çok sıklıkla gidip gelip
özellikle çalıştığım alanlarda Hem
uluslararası ilişkiler hem de iletişim
olan alanında
kendimi birazcık daha geliştirmeyi ve
Türkiye'yi tanıtmak için çalışmalar
yapmaya başladım bir önemli adımın
Hindistan'a gitmekle oldu Onu
Hindistan'a gittiğim zaman gerçekten
farklı bir kültür ve farklı bir ülkede
farklı insanlarla çalışmak Bana çok
büyük şeyler öğretti Hindistan her
canlıya nasıl saygıyla yaklaştıklarını
birazcık daha
farklı kültürlerin ve farklı bakış
açısının İnsanın kendisini
geliştirmesine ne kadar önemli olduğunu
gösterdi ve şunu tavsiye edebilirim ki
bütün hayatımız boyunca aslında
alacağınız Burslar ya da atacağınız adım
da
attığınız Aslında her küçük adım bir
sonraki büyük adımızın tuğlası oluyor
taşı oluyor Dolayısıyla kendi
yollarımıza
taşları bu şekilde düşüne biliyorsunuz
Bu arada saati göremiyorum artık kafan
dış bunu sonra Ama daha zamanı
doldurmadım
O yüzden size tavsiyem Şu olabilir
özellikle
hayallerinizin peşinden gitmeniz çok
önemli bi Cesur olmanız Çok önemli çünkü
Ben cesaret etmeseydim Eğer bazı şeylere
yapamazsın dedikleri noktalarda
dursaydım
O zaman gerçekten sanırım hedeflediğim
yerlere ulaşamaz dım başarısız
olabilirsiniz başarısız doldum başarısız
olduğun şeylerde
kendimle barışık olmayı öğrendim En
azından şunu söyledim denedim neden
yapamadığını gördüm bir Keşkem kalmadı i
bu kalmadı Örneğin şöyle bir şey yaşadım
Çok ciddi iki kaza geçirdim bir
tanesinde kafatasında çökme oluştu
Diğerini de dirsek kapsülün kırıldı ve
dirsek kapsülün kırıldığında doktor bana
kesinlikle bir daha kolunu şuradan daha
fazla açamazsın dedi tenis oyuncusuyum
ve benim için kabus gözyaşıma alerjim
var Ağlayamıyorum böyle değişik bir
durumdayım Yani ne yapacağım bundan
sonra diye
kendi alçımı kendim çıkarttım Bence
zamanı geldi diye yani attığım en kötü
adımlardan bir tanesi de onu
söyleyebilirim sonra apar topar tekrar
doktora gittik ama
bütün egzersizleri yaptım kendim
Araştırmalar yaptım Nasıl düzeltebilirim
diye şu anda gerçekten tenis oynamaya
geri dönmek oğlum da istediğim gibi
açabiliyorum Dolayısıyla Sadece bize
söylenen
tenler L ilerlemek yerine kendi
kapasitenizi bilirsiniz neler
yapabileceğinizi sizin Ellerim da
olabileceğini bilirsiniz attığınız bütün
Küçük Kadınlar sonunda size o Sıçacağız
büyük adıma götürüyor bir en son önemli
adımın minik Benim kedim bir hayvan
sahiplenmek Tea çünkü beni her konuda
eğitim İnik Dört yaşına kadar çok normal
bir kediydi 4 yaşından sonra Epilepsi
hastası olduğu ortaya çıktı Her gün
düzenli ilaç almak zorunda ben işte
taylanda gidelim Hindistan'a giderim
hayatımı özgürce yaşarım derken bir
canlıya duyduğunuz sorumluluğun aslında
sizi nasıl kısıtladığı ve bundan da
Mutluluk duyduğunuz Yani o benim için en
büyük derslerden biriydi daha sonra
damağında lezyon çıktığı inanılmaz artar
damara kadar gitmiş kanamalar sürekli
unutalım diyorlar Hayır dedim mücadele
edeceğiz ve bir çiçek çiçeği bakar gibi
bir kediye baktı baktım bir dönem oldu
sürekli veterinerlerde ama sonunda
Onunda çaresini bulduk ve Ne oldu
tedavisi ile birlikte gayet güzel
hayatını sürdürüyor ama bir canlının
sorumluluğunu almak ve ona gerçekten
sevgi vermek ve emek vermek sanırım
Hayatımın her döneminde etki eden en
büyük adımdı diyebilirim vaktimi
doldurdum Çok teşekkür ediyorum
[Alkış]
şu
mor o